ce reportage. Le diagnostic
est donc très, très sombre.
On va essayer maintenant,
aujourd'hui, de cibler
les causes. On a invité
Normand Baillargeon, qui
est philosophe et essayiste,
à essayer avec nous de répondre
à ces questions, quelles sont
les causes. Bonsoir, Normand.
- Bonsoir Mme Drolet.
- Alors, dites-nous,
d'abord, qu'est-ce qui cloche
dans notre système d'éducation?
Comment ça se fait qu'on se
retrouve avec des gens
été qualifiés,
dans le reportage, carrément
d'analphabètes fonctionnels?
NORMAND BAILLARGEON
philosophe et essayiste
- Oui, ça, c'est très sévère,èr,
puis on aimerait avoir
un portrait globale exhaustif
et juste de ce qui se passe.
Mais il y a des raisons d'être
inquiet. Moi, je me félicite
que le public, vous dites
que vous avez eu beaucoup
de réactions, s'inquiète de
tout ça, et c'est certainement
multicausal, Madame Drolet,
faut examiner
l'ensemble de la situation.
On pourra pas nuancer comme
il le conviendrait en quelques
minutes aujourd'hui, mais
on peut pointer un certain
nombre de choses qui sont
présentes, qui sont bien
réelles et qui contribuent
à faire qu'on ait des problèmes
avec la lecture.
- Si on avait une première cause
a nommer, une des choses
qui a beaucoup frappé nos
téléspectateurs, qui ont été
nombreux, comme vous le dites,àe
dire : on fait pas assez de
dictées ou, quand on en fait,
on n'évalue pas les fautes,
en fait, les fautes ne comptent
pas, com.. alors,
à quoi bon faire des dictées
si n'on enlève pas des points?
- Il y a certainement
des problèmes qui tiennent
à la manseigner,
à lire et à écrire. C'est
un dossier très complexe,
celui-là aussi. Une chose
que j'aimerais d'abord dire,
c'est qu'il existe à ce sujet
des données probantes, des
manières meilleures d'apprendre
à lire et à écrire et
on ne les suit pas toujours.
Une exception, par exemple,
c'est tout récemment,
un programme pour le préscolaire
qui, luindé sur
les données probantes, mais
étrangement, il a suscité
un tollé. C'est extrêmement
décevant. Un autre aspect de
ce problème-là, certainement,
c'est la formation des
enseignants. Les étudiants
qui sont admis dans les facultés
d'éducation sont souvent très
faibles. La formation qu'on leur
donne est déficiente et pas
toujours fondée sur les données
probantes. On se retrouve
en ce moment au Québec avec
un phénomène de désertion
professionnelle, de pénuried'ent
être extrêmement préoccupants,
et ça, ça se vérifie, ça se voit
dans l'enseignement du français
extrêmement triste
de voir ça.
- On a entendu, d'ailleurs, en
reportage et on a refait jouer
l'extrait tantôt pour que l
gens nous suivent dans la
discussion. Un enseignant qui
disait : parfois, sont capables
de lire, étudiants, rendus à aus
ils ont un problème avec le
sens. Par exemple, il n'arrive
pas à saisir l'ironie dans un
texte. Comment c'est possibl
- C'est une très belle remarque
et, aussi, c'est peut-être une
des choses les plus importantes
que je voudrais transmettre ce
soir. Lire, c'est d'abord
effectivement décodé et savoir
lire des mots. Et là, on s'est
souvent fondé sur des méthodes
Et là, ici, on s'est souvent
fondé sur des méthodes qui sont
pas les meilleures pour
apprendre à lire. Revenons-y
aussi tout à l'heure. Mais
ensuite, lire, c'est aussi avoir
une culture générale qui permet
de comprendre ce qu'on lit.
Et si on n'a pas cette culture
générale, on a beaucoup de mal
à comprendre un grand nombr
de choses. L'ironie est
un excellent exemple.
Laissez-moi donner un exemple
tout simple : on peut apprendre
à lire et connaître le mot
"donner", mais on ne connaîtra
pas le sens différent
à chaque fois des expressionson,
"donner un dollar",
"donner une injection",
"donner un bain",
"donner du fil à retordre".
Et là, complexifiez ça encore
et vous allez voir que, si
on n'a pas de culture générale,
si le curriculum transmis
ne correure
générale qu'on doit avoir,
on aura du mal à lire des
textes, à décoder l'ironie
parce qu'on aura pas le savoir
préalable nécessaire pour faire
ça. Ces données-là sont établies
depuis très longtemps en
éducation... je tiens à saluer
Jane Charles, la dame qui a
travaillé sur ces questions-là,
elle appelait ca la retombée
en quatrième année et
l'effondrement de quatrième
année parce qu'on n'a pas la
culture nécessaire pour lire les
livres et les textes et pour
apprécier les nuances, pour
apprécier l'ironie et ainsi de
suite.
- Mais c'est très grave ce queti
parce que finalement, nos jeunes
qui vont à l'école, ils font
tout le primaire, ils font le
secondaire, il se retrouve au
cégep et vous dîtes : ils ont
pas eu accès à ce socle commun
de culture.
- C'est effectivement grave,
c'est effectivement triste.
Et encore plus triste,
si vous me permettez,raison sui:
la chose se présente comme
ceci : il y a des enfants
qui ont la chance d'avoir
à la maison accès à une c
générale, leurs parents lisent,
possèdent des livres, achètent
des revues. D'autres enfants ne
possèdent pas cet avantage-là.Ie
sans cet avantage qu'on confère
aux autres : l'apprentissage
de toutes ces choses qu'ils ont
à la maour
ces gens-là, c'est l'école
pour rattraper les autres.
Et si l'école le fait pas, enco.
Ajoutez à ça que chez nous,
on a un système qui est en fait
triplement distribué : une école
publique commune,
publique avec des programmes
spéciaux, une école privée,
et là, vous voyez s'accentuer
les inégalités, les injustic
je crains pas de le dire le mot,
qui touchent à l'apprentissage
de la lecture, bien sûr,
mais de l'accès à la cult
- On n'a pas encore parlé d
se réseaux sociaux, d'Internet,
des téléséries, Netflixgnie. Lae
de l'anglais qui est très, très
présente auprès de nos jeunes
justement par le biais
de tout ces outils
Est-ce que ça, ça compte
dans l'équation?
- Je pense que ça compte sans
aucun doute dans l'équation,
vous avez bien raison
de le souligner. En ce moment,
il y a un aspect social
et politique à toute cette
question-là qui concerne
le déclin du français, le manque
de valorisation, la culture
française, la grande placequ'oce
et effectivement, les réseaux
sociaux. Des travaux se font
de plus en plus sur ces
est complexe,
mais c'est évident que ça joue
un rôle. Ça joue un rôle dans
la capacité de se concentrer,
la capacité de con
du temps à quelque chose,
de lire avec effort.
Toutes ces choses-là sont
à prendre en compte et à nuancer
quand on essaie d'expliquer
la situation complexe qu'on
décrit.
- Et là, si on veut en rajo
une couche, on a aussi
ces étudiants qui sont
à l'université pour devenir
les futurs enseignants,mais euxs
au niveau et doivent refaire
les examens obligatoires
de français à plusieurs
reprises. Parfois,
arrivent carrément pas,
puis ils changent de programme.
Tout ça est très révélateur
sur même la qualité de la relèv.
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire,
Normand Baillargeon?
On a l'impression qu'il faut
tout rebrasser.
- C'est une vaste question
et vous avez tout à fait raison
de souligner ça. Les étudiants
admis, les étudiantes admises
à l'université po
enseignants sont souvent
les étudiants parmi les plus
faibles qui accèdent
à l'université. Ensuite, j'ait ,
mais souvent, les facultés
d'éducation transmettent...
ne transmettent pas les savoirs
les mieux fondés sur les données
probantes, transmettent et font
apprendre des pseudos sciences,
ce qui est extrêmement
dommageable, ce qui fait que les
gens qui arrivent
pour enseigner ont été
mal préparés par la formation
qu'ils ont reçue. Beaucoup
quittent le domaine en quelquesi
de désertion professionnelle.
Et les facultés d'éducation
ne parviennent pas à nous donner
les enseignants dont on a
besoin. On est en pénurie
d'enseignants. C'est dramatique.
Vous me demandez ce qu'on fait,
moi, ça fait déjà plusieursannét
pas à moi de régler cette
question-là. Ce n'est pas
aux facultés d'éducation à elles
seules d
C'est à une réflexion collective
de fond à la lumière des données
probantes qui permettraient
aux Québécois et aux Québécoises
de décider ce qu'ils veulent
du système d'éducation
et comment on doit le construire
pour parvenir aux objectifsqu'o.
- Donc, c'est quoi? On s'engage
vers une nouvelle commission
de  pare
- Je l'ai appelée comme ça,
la commissions parents 2.0.
J'aimerais beaucoup que
quelque chose comm
au Québec. Et quand je vois
la réaction des gens à votre
reportage, quand j'entends aussi
les gens parler autour de moi,
je crois qu'il y a un grand
souci pour l'éducation,
peut-être plus grand que celui
qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
tion
générale est mûre pour ça,
va se soucier encore une fois
de transmettre de l'éducation,
de transmettre de la culture,
de transmettre du savoir, de
transmettre le goût de lire
parce que ce serait triste
de pas terminer notre rencontre
aujourd'hui entre
disant que l'accès à la lecture,
c'est l'accès à des plaisirs
extraordinaires. Et on est
privés de ça on ne lit pas
et si on
préalable pour aller lire
Molière puis l'apprécier,
pour aller lire Michel Tremblay
et l'apprécier, pour comprendre
les chansons de Br
et ainsi de suite.
- Noël s'en vient. C'est un beau
cadeau, un livre. Il ne faut pas
l'oublier. Normand Baillargeon,
c'est to
de vous recevoir en entrevue.
Merci beaucoup.
- C'est moi qui vous remercie